[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
>> Judge Jeanine: WELCOME BACK
FROM HOLLYWOOD, FLORIDA, THE
DEMOCRATS GEARING UP FOR AN
AMNESTY FREE-FOR-ALL IN A MOVE
THAT IS ONLY GOING TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE AT THE BORDER.
CHUCK SCHUMER SAYS WE SHOULD
WELCOME WITH OPEN ARMS MILLIONS
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> IMMIGRANTS MAKE US STRONGER
NOW MORE THAN EVER.
NOW MORE THAN EVER!
WE ARE SHORT OF WORKERS, WE HAVE
A POPULATION THAT IS NOT
REPRODUCING ON ITS OWN WITH THE
SAME LEVEL THAT IT USED TOO.
THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A GREAT FUTURE IN AMERICA
IS IF WE WELCOME AND EMBRACE
IMMIGRANTS.
THE DREAMERS AND ALL OF THEM,
BECAUSE OUR ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO
HELP THE DREAMERS BUT GET A PATH
TO CITIZENSHIP FOR ALL
11 MILLION OR HOWEVER MANY
UNDOCUMENTED THERE ARE HERE.
>> Judge Jeanine: BUT BOY,
WHAT A CONTRAST FROM 2009 WHEN
CHUCK WAS SINGING A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT TUNE.
>> ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS WRONG,
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
UNTIL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CONVINCED THAT WE WILL STOP
FUTURE FLOWS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, WE WILL MAKE NO
PROGRESS ON DEALING WITH THE
MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WHO ARE HERE NOW AND ON
RATIONALIZING OUR SYSTEM OF
LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL RIGHT,
HAROLD, SO HERE YOU HAVE
CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING, YOU KNOW,
11 MILLION OR WHATEVER, WE NEED
TO BRING HIM IN AND MAKE AMERICA
STRONGER, AND THEN YOU HAVE
JOE BIDEN WHO IS ALLOWING ALL OF
THIS TO HAPPEN.
YOU HAVE MAORYKS SAYING THE
BORDER IS SECURE, ISN'T THIS THE
DEMOCRATIC AGENDA AND TO WHAT
AND THAT WILL BE?
>> Harold: I HOPE NOT.
I'M A DEMOCRAT AND I CERTAINLY
DON'T SUPPORT THE PATH THAT YOU
THINK SOME DEMOCRATS ARE ON.
I'VE HAD FOR A LONG TIME THIS IS
A 4-5 PRONG SOLUTION.
>> Judge Jeanine: IS AMNESTY
THE SOLUTION?
>> Harold: NO, SO I HOPE WHAT
THEY WERE DOING THEIR WAS
THROWING OUT A PIE-IN-THE-SKY
IDEA WITH THE HOPES THAT THEY
WILL BRING PEOPLE TO THE TABLE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE GET ANY
ANSWER.
I SAID YESTERDAY MANY TIMES ON
THE SHOW, BUILD A WALL.
YOU SEND MORE JUDGES COMING TO
PUT MORE ICE THEY ARE, YOU HAVE
TO CHANGE SOME PERSONNEL IN A
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND THEY
WILL GET SOME OF THIS DONE, BUT
WE HAVE TO SECURE THE BORDER FOR
NATIONAL SECURITY REASONS BEFORE
WE CAN HAVE ANY CONVERSATION
ABOUT, WHICH I BELIEVE WE DO
NEED MORE WORKERS IN THIS
COUNTRY, BUT UNTIL WE SECURE THE
BORDER, WE WON'T HAVE A
COALITION IN CONGRESS AND THE
SENATE.
>> Judge Jeanine: GIVEN THAT
CHUCK SCHUMER IS A MAJORITY
LEADER IN THE SENATE, THEY HAVE
THE HOUSE RIGHT NOW AND THEY
HAVE THE OVAL, DO YOU THINK THEY
CAN MOVE FAST ENOUGH IN BEFORE
THE ELECTION SO THAT THEY HAVE
THEM IN LEGAL AND READY TO VOTE
IN 2024?
>> Jesse: LAME DUCK THAT
AMNESTY?
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN PULL IT
OFF.
BUT THEY HAD BOTH CHAMBERS UNDER
BARACK OBAMA AND BOTH CHAMBERS
UNDER JOE BIDEN, WHY DIDN'T THEY
DO IMMIGRATION REFORM THEN?
THE MINUTE THEY TAKE THE HOUSE
AND THEY WANT TO DO AMNESTY?
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
THEY DON'T WANT TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM, THEY WANT TO CAMPAIGN
ON THE PROBLEM AND THEY WANT TO
PAINT REPUBLICANS AS
ANTI-HISPANIC.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS, IT IS JUST
A POLITICAL GAME.
[APPLAUSE]
AND HE IS ALSO, IF AMERICANS
AREN'T HAVING BABIES, WHY CAN'T
WE JUST HAVE MORE BABIES?
WHY DO WE HAVE TO BRING IN
FOREIGNERS TO HAVE THE BABIES WE
WON'T HAVE, MAYBE WE JUST GET
OFF OUR iPHONES AND DIM THE
LIGHTS, JUDGE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU CAN DO
IT TONIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, DANA, WHAT IS YOUR
RESPONSE?
>> Dana: I THINK CHUCK SCHUMER
IS BEING SUPER IRRESPONSIBLE IN
SEVERAL DIFFERENT ISSUES OVER
TIME AND SAYING THAT YOU WANT TO
DO AMNESTY WITHOUT ACTUALLY
ADDRESSING THE CURRENT BORDER
PROBLEM ENSURES THAT YOU WILL
NOT GET A LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION
AND YOU KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN CAN
DO AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO TRY TO
FIX IT, BECAUSE THAT WILL END UP
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AS WELL.
SO TONIGHT AT THE PATRIOT
AWARDS, YOU ARE GOING TO SEE A
SERGEANT FROM THE TEXAS CPP, OR
DPS I THINK IT IS CALLED, TEXAS
DPS SOMEBODY WHO IS A PILOT AND
TRACKS DOWN SMUGGLERS AND THEN
GOES AND BASICALLY WILL FIND YOU
AS A HUMAN TRACKER, THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRAFFICKING HUMANS HE
WOULD FIND A SMUGGLER, AND
THAT'S WHAT HE DOES EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
WHEN HIS LIFE IS IN DANGER, THE
SITUATION IS SO MUCH WORSE THAN
HE HAS EVER SEEN BEFORE AND WE
WILL HONOR HIM TONIGHT AT THE
FOX PATRIOT AWARDS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL RIGHT,
GREG, WHAT IS THE RESOLUTION?
>> Greg: FIRST OF ALL YOUR
REMINDING ME FROM THE A BLOCK
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION
THAT AS ONE OF THE HEARINGS THAT
WE HAVE TO INVESTIGATE AND FIND
OUT WHY THEY KNEW THAT WAS NOT A
WHIP BUT DECIDED NOT TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT, SOMETHING THAT IT'S
REALLY VALUABLE, CHUCK SCHUMER
SAYS AND MISTY UP ARE ALL COMING
GUYS REMIND ME OF THE PENGUIN
BUT WITHOUT THE CHARMS.
AND JUST NEEDS A TOP HAT AND A
CANE AND A MONOCLE, AND HE SAYS
AMNESTY FOR ALL BECAUSE HE KNOWS
THAT'S NOT A COMPROMISE, HE
ACTUALLY DOES NOT WANT IT AND IS
NOT GOING ANYWHERE NEAR HALFWAY,
BUT HYSTERICAL POINTS ARE
INTERESTING, THE DECLINING
POPULATION IS TRUE, AND ALSO THE
DESIRE FOR CHEAP LABOR,
DEMOCRATS LOVE CHEAP LABOR, WHO
CAN FORGET SLAVERY, THAT'S WHERE
HE IS COMING FROM.
AND BY THE WAY, THE REASON
WHY -- WHY WAS THIS CREATED?
PEOPLE DON'T NEED TO WORK
ANYMORE BECAUSE OF STIMULUS.
PEOPLE ARE AT HOME.
YOU TALK TO PEOPLE IN THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY COMING TO TALK TO
PEOPLE IN THE BARS, THERE AREN'T
PEOPLE SHOWING UP FOR WORK
ANYMORE, BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
TO.
SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT NOW
IS A TEMPORARY SOLUTION FOR
SOMETHING, A TERRIBLE EXPERIMENT
OF WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT GUARANTEED BASIC INCOME?
THAT'S WHERE YOU PAY PEOPLE EVEN
IF THEY ARE NOT WORKING.
WE JUST DID THAT TO YOUR
EXPERIMENT AND IT WAS A
DISASTER.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION?
BUST IN WORKERS.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS DOING.
THEY ACTUALLY CREATED